let me have your attention a moment
cause you're talking about what talking
about bitching about YouTube D
monetization
some son of a [ __ ] in Silicon Valley is
screwing with your subscriber count'
somebody's screwing your notification
system let's talk about something
important they all hear all the one well
I'm going anyway let's talk about
something important
put the coffee down coffee's for mud
clubbers only you think I'm [ __ ] with
you I am NOT I'm here from downtown
I'm here from CR TV and I'm here on a
mission of mercy your name's not gay
Jared yeah you call yourself a mud club
salesman you son of a [ __ ] I certainly
don't pal because the good news is
you're fired the bad news is you've got
you've all got just one week to regain
your jobs at ladder with Crowder
starting with tonight starting with
tonight's it Oh have I got your
attention now
good cuz we're adding a little something
to this month's sales contest as you all
know first prize is a brand new decked
out sony fs7 anyone want to see second
prize second prize is a pair of Ranger
panties third prize is you're fired
you're starting to get the picture are
you laughing now you've got subscribers
Mudd Club paid good money get their
names to get them to join Mudd Club
you can't tune into subscribers you're
given you can't tune in [ __ ] you are
[ __ ] hit the bricks pal because you're
getting banned the notification system
is weak the notifications are weak the
notification systems weak you're weak
I've been in this business 15 years
what's your name
[ __ ] you that's my name
you know why mister cuz you drove here
in a shitty news van tonight and I in an
$80,000 BMW that's my name and your name
is your wanting you can't reach your own
YouTube subscribers because you two do
not even notifying people go home and
tell your wife your troubles there's
only one thing that counts in this life
and that is to get them to sign on the
club that is muck you hear me you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
a B M a a always B B M Mudd clubbing
always be mug clubbing always the mud
clubbing a I D a tension interest
decision action attention YouTube's not
notifying you of ladder with Carter's
new videos do I have your attention
interest are you interested
I know you are you even hit the
notification bell you close or you hit
the bricks decision have you made your
decision for Mudd Club and actually a I
D hey get out there you've got the
subscribers coming in I think they came
in to get out of the rain
guy don't hit the notification bill
unless he wants to see your videos
they're out there just waiting to give
you their support are you gonna take it
are you man enough to take it incredible
what's the problem pal you [ __ ] kraut
you're such a hero you're so rich baby
how come you're coming down here waste
your time with such a bunch of bumps
that mug see that mug yeah that mug is
hand etched
this year I signed Phil Robertson Gavin
McGinnis and Roman millennial how many
did you recruit you see pal that's who I
am and you're an intern nice guy I don't
give a [ __ ] good computer [ __ ] you go
home and play with your floppy disk you
want to work here close
you think this is abuse you think this
is abuse you [ __ ]
you can't handle this how the hell will
you handle the abuse you get out there
in a youtube comment section you don't
like it leave I can go out there tonight
the materials you've got and get 15,000
new Mudd Club members tonight in two
hours you you go and do likewise hey yes
youtubers with your subscribers yes half
your subscribers hitting notification
bell aren't even receiving them in
people should be joining my club and
bookmarking your page get mad you sons
of [ __ ] get mad do you know what it
takes
come on back
it takes hand etched hand-painted balls
to grow my club go and do likewise Jets
my clubs for closers
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's about how much snap is coming
away today like naka jeered throwing
that jab and the Courtney's face when
they do their kickboxing match
because incredible guests today we have
we have Elon Musk oh yeah Ryan Bader Oh
Blair white we have Ben Shapiro and we
have Owen Benjamin Owen Benjamin with I
believe later on a little little did he
uh so big show a lot of news to get to a
lot of news to get to with North Korea
that's been happening and of course Iran
we haven't talked about it that much
this week because we wanted to see it
play out spoiler alert
not very well uh producing them in video
studio as always is Jared who is not gay
follow me on Twitter not guide you and
me tusk right with the comment your
thoughts your photoshop's we've got a
great Photoshop recently what's a
portrait of me with hopper and Kramer
saying I guess it's not a no not of
Photoshop so much as a painting ah
send them we love them I'm gonna get
that up in the studio I fulfilled my
legal obligations during conclusions are
we good G Morgan Jr at G Morgan Jr
simplify Dwayne calm he drinks a lot I
do usually be considered a wino but you
slap a title on him sommelier and all of
a sudden he has more taste buds what's
the one okay perfect she had to say
Michelle ethos Chateau say Michelle
ethos all mushrooms you say Michelle so
it sounds like a girl's name haze fan
with the overlays are you ready that's
funny I was giving you hope see I was
giving you hope I was giving you home
I'm ready be people a sign of peace in
the Runyan sense I want to you can go up
those Germans you can go straight to
where Angela Merkel dwells
is this Walther shirt day and I didn't
get the memo like no I don't know by the
way Walter don't say that you didn't get
more than you paid for I do love their
firearms question of the day before we
move on why should the UN in relation to
North Korea in Iran why should the USA
give a rat's ass as to what other
countries think about us our
responsibilities our military what we
need to give to NATO haven't we reached
the point regardless of whether you like
President Trump or not have we reached
the poor where we say you know what
Germany we you know what France you know
what insert any country that's not the
United States here especially Canada
you've lost your say comment I'd love to
see what you a genuinely I must have
asked this question before no arse never
know I never asked it thanks
for saving the entire world well we have
to move on to more important news before
we get to that Roman Polanski apparently
came out and he dismissed the hashtag me
too movement as mass hysteria from NBC
News is an interview with a Polish
Newsweek the director said the me to
reckoning is an example of quote
collective hysteria that occasionally
grips society leading people to react
mostly out of fear yes responded to
throngs of underage girls he sodomized
on quaaludes Roman Polanski was Bill
Cosby not available I couldn't get Woody
Allen on the payroll quaaludes money'll
millennial rape victims are so spoiled
yes of all people hashtag shut up like
listen you managed to avenge us you
managed to avoid arrest
shut up take the W and go away okay it
could get a lot worse if we don't report
this I guess real news I get an op
nights Diller who speaks out on gun
control now
yes exactly I'll be stay tuned a woman
on Huffington Post but I don't know any
other way it's hard for me to explain
this in a way yeah this is interesting
that provides content I'm gonna do my
best so at HuffPo this lady is now
saying that theme parks fat-shamed
guests when they don't let them enjoy
all the rides this is a direct quotes as
well safety is often the given reason
that fat people are excluded it's clear
that companies are actually just keeping
the general public safe from our fatness
I refuse to take on the additional guilt
of not having gotten into Harry Potter
until I was 35 okay first off those
Muslim terrestrially I want you to think
of the words that I just spoke in the
order I spoke them to form that sentence
kill yourself because it's worse than
Stephen King's the mist you don't want
to be here for the rest of it slow this
girl was right this was the person who
was banned I guess from Harry Potter
world for being sofa I've been on those
rides by the way yeah they're not very
girthy yeah okay I've been I was next to
a girthy person there so I'm surprised
if this person couldn't fit then it must
been really bad but then a person
Huffington Post was writing about it
chiming in like like velociraptors
communicating over their fatness and she
wrote I'll admit that despite the
annoying JK Rowling versus Nate
people scandal that I doubt you've heard
anything about but I followed because
I'm native so this is the author at
Huffington Post right right to the fat
Native American victim card so I guess
this [ __ ] needs a smallpox tarp okay I
am so I mean I just I cannot read enough
an impost who I can't stand right about
people who I can't stand for you because
you can't be bothered because you don't
want to read up and in post I don't
blame you if you think that's like
somewhere deep in the article no she
lied she that was the lead I was the
lead which is funny you know you don't
even really think of indigenous people
as fat generally but this writer HuffPo
she claims to be a part of the I want to
make sure I get this right for fear of
HuffPo writers claims to be a part of
the Minik Apache Tribe which actually
from its native tongue translates to one
who requires the north wall to her
apartment be broken down when she has a
stroke a peaceful journey into the
afterlife young coronary
may you be kept safe till you see the
great red chief Ronald Weasley oh fat
are you that you couldn't make it to the
venture through Hogwarts another story
people are gonna like this a flaming
rabbit has now been blamed officially
for sparking Saskatchewan wildfire this
comes from my home so for those dopes
land fire was carried out by a fire
department at beardies and oka meeseeks
Creek nation unfortunately after a
controlled burn was conducted and
thought to be extinguished a rabbit on
fire lit another adjacent section of
bush they should have never let that
little prick volunteers tribute it's in
the name what did you accept it what did
you expect the statue I you know do you
know how pissed smokey the bear is made
you famous like a brother to be the
fight is flame flowing rabbits hey a
Texas school is now making headlines is
this and we're gonna get to Iran North
Korea trust me but it's it's it's been a
long week
they're making headlines for their
tradition of birthday spankings yeah
it's comes from a CVS local station in
Texas it's been a tradition for eight
years at Alvord elementary school for
principal Bridget Williams to give
students quote birthday spankings until
recently when parents complained calling
it inappropriate kinda many parents
defended principal Williams of parents
saying parents like Heather redder
saying they're not used to a small-town
community and that's what we are people
that move you from the big city they
don't realize they're not used to this
because a lot of people are moving from
the big city and the Texas for the
economy so it's truly and it's changed
the culture the practice has since been
exchanged with birthday quote light
joking and putting your hand in its
mouth so that's it's almost like you're
exchanging one for something worse so
what are ya is like can I go back a
major in that drop your [ __ ] egg see
the guest lecturer cuz uh I'm an expert
in the field and we have guest lecturers
at grade schools listen they give guests
bankers though apparently that's right
would you like to spank our children and
then listen I thought I think we're
Panza fied and you and I read this going
like oh geez birthday spankings Wow Wow
it was a guy someone someone someone
searched that principal's office because
I guarantee you there's a poster on the
wall like Shawshank we're gonna carve
out a hole and find a sex dungeon in
there
in other news principal different New
York mayoral candidate Cynthia Nixon
came out and said that pot could be a
form of reparations in black
neighborhood that's good
so nation on Saturday told Forbes yeah
we have to make sure that communities
that have been harmed and devastated by
because because sometimes people say
you're afraid to do the black lady voice
because of political crisis I just don't
think of it you're welcome have been
devastated by marijuana arrest get the
first shot at this industry it's a form
of reparations and Reverend Al Sharpton
I kid you not came out and tweeted quote
let's bring this you have it send
computer let's bring this up I'm
legalizing marijuana and I like Cynthia
Nixon but putting pot shops and our
communities is not reparations what the
black community needs most
moment or teleprompters to build a
movement of resistance but resist we
much we mum goes the dynamite
note to Cynthia Nixon when Al Sharpton
calls you out for race baiting you're
too hot it's too I you bet you have puff
pass put away you gotta respect the game
yeah respect the game yeah campaign
managers read man speaking of the
chronic dr. Dre just lost a trademark
battle with a gynecologist called dr.
Dee Rai dr. Dre yeah this comes from the
BBC the cases first 2015 is on the case
for a kid first came up when
gynecologist Dre on and Burch tried to
trademark the name dr. Dre the other dr.
Dre this sounds confusing objected
saying the similarity could cause quote
confusion especially as is near name
sake you wanted to sell audio books and
seminars under the monitor hey okay
listen let's not what dr. Dre you're not
a real doctor and you're also not a real
Dre Dr Dre should now be known as
illegally unlicensed charlatan Andre
also it turns out Snoop Dogg is not even
a real dog but surprisingly is a
proctologist
yeah likes to snoop them dog yes get
over there
do some time in prison there I'm yeah bu
TT so vape pens apparently now it's who
are exploding in people's faces a
pandemic exhibit a story from this week
this guy this is Idaho car salesman
Andrew Hall formerly an enthusiastic
vapor but andrew has vowed to quit
smoking for good after his vape pen blew
up in his face motion House of the
weekend when Andrew was enjoying a few
don't know quell getting ready for work
and you wrote on Facebook that he was
vaping in his bathroom ooh now that's
good I see you Facebook and then posted
from the ICU who is thought to be a
faulty battery though a new scientific
investigation ex is a common it's been
happening a lot throughout the country
really reveals that it's actually a
chemical combustion that occurs when
nicotine reacts with too much douche you
drew me in there punk what did you see
yeah what does it take to start a
national conversation about vape culture
I don't know did you see the explosion
by the way for people who are listening
audio or people go what go look at the
picture there's like the drywall is gone
there's soot all over the what was he
vaping an ACME firecracker
what's the roadrunner in the bathtub
with a plunger beeping aah Oh an
Instagram it's so bad the explosions
beep oh anvil lost his teeth everywhere
I kind of hate vapors anyway and when he
was asked to what's the crazy thing when
he was asked if he was concerned about
his teeth as much as the the damage to
the wall and what bothered him most he
said I know it wasn't so much concerned
about his teeth quote as much as my flat
build semi sideways baseball cap which I
wear indoors because I never had a dad
though he was no stranger to actually
losing teeth due to quote people always
punching me in the face for my flat
build semi sideways baseball cap that I
wear indoors because I never had a dad
[Laughter]
this is why father's matter yes this is
why I don't know I don't like papers
they feel like they can do it anywhere I
had person do it in a wine tasting I
don't really care they'd rather your
favorite other vape explosives they
better do it the Croesus surplice vaping
population I say don't change a thing
hey speaking of things that people are
gonna get mad about Elon Musk I know you
guys all he's your darling he's better
known for Tesla someone saying SpaceX is
now starting a candy company he tweeted
out that he's starting a candy company
and it's going to be amazing when people
thought it was a joke he later went on
to say quote super serious so um you
know this is a topic that's been
capturing the public's attention and we
wanted to talk with him about it I
believe we have Elon Musk
do we have a Miss line mr. musk thank
you for being with us sir thanks for
having me Steven absolutely so Elon the
first question this begs candy industry
why why would you the canned industry is
one of the few that has been stagnant
for decades as a matter of fact in our
lifetimes the canned industry has
remained almost completely unchanged in
merit but agriculture and industrial
revolutions let alone digital uh-huh I'm
having a little trouble direction and
which is what I plan to disrupt with my
new confections theme you know you keep
saying that I'm not entirely sure with
that what are you what are you doing -
soda pop rock delicious and renewable
yeah I'm not I don't think that's
exactly going to catch on mr. Ilan I
don't think that's going to be a well
Osby complimented by our new wind
turbine fields man hi y'all gummy see I
don't think that your target demographic
namely six-year-olds are gonna be overly
concerned with with that with renewable
energy bodies ring pops yeah which can
launch into space
that sounds in expensive of course
subsidized ah well of course mr. mr.
musk um what do you say to critics is
just a move to distract from the fact
that you may be removed as a chairman
that a test was soon that this could be
a little bit of smoke world will always
have critics to them I simply say come
with me this is incredibly a world of
pure imagination take a look and help me
okay Elon yeah yeah I think that's
enough with with your singing and I have
a flair for showmanship but a trance do
you think we'd have more common ground
on this then you would expect okay all
right I'm willing to listen house
make paradise simply open up your
wallets anything you want to do it want
me to change the world just a few
billion yeah that's pretty much what I
expected that's enough Elon Musk
everybody I don't yeah I don't know I
don't need to think about it
come on cut him off I don't think we
need to have Elon Musk on the program by
the way ever see use fan and Elon in the
same room mm-hmm I don't like it
they spent updated so now we're gonna
get to the topic of the day which I know
everyone here has strong opinions on of
course of course
um North Korea Iran this all went down
this week and then of course Angela
Merkel entered the fray today course
Germany so it's this amalgamation of
foreign policy cluster F the likes of
which we haven't seen spend update us
here what's been what's happened here
this last week with North Korea in Iran
because I know you've got the overlay
yeah well this last week what basically
happened is that the United States I
should say we will allow it that my
prepare got the hostages back yeah from
North Korea and as well crumples out of
the Iran deal exactly we pull out of
that deal and there's a meeting with Kim
jong-un and Singapore June 12th it was
going really well until President Trump
said that he treated those three really
well damnit exactly but you okay you've
got to separate the fact you exactly
take the W and walk okay president Rome
you've got a separate defect as some
dumb things versus our position in the
globe right now here's all the time
people say like all the United States is
more respected internationally I don't
wanna know if that's the case no and we
certainly weren't respecting the sense
of being feared or respected by people
like Kim Jong Un's are the same were
respected less internationally they were
same with respected more international
Barack Obama I want to make sure I get
that right it was absolutely the
opposite just being rolled by the rest
of world doesn't mean that you're being
respected by them right you need some
brightening office who can wield the
power like they attributed it's purely
the fact that he went on in what
Pollard's long apology Oh much of all
the nations yeah much longer is it was
an eight-year apology yeah well he was
saying that we want to be like those
guys we don't wanna be like those guys
we're better
sorry and then he did it a bowing encore
yeah
so for example North Korea Obama tried
for years to come up with a way to stop
their nuclear program he failed it's any
basically handed 1.7 billion dollars to
arraign for no apparent reason there's
really spies finding out that they
continued surprise their nuclear program
so Donald Trump pulled out of the
nuclear that the nuclear Iran nuclear
deal okay which of course all the left
they were praising it they said that
this is a way to try and avoid some kind
of a conflict so when the news broke
that President Donald Trump like it you
can confirm this is authentic right
Svend computer yes this is from memory
TV this is another entick clip I want to
make sure if Sven computer says it it's
you know it's true so when we found out
Iran that Donald Trump pulled out of the
deal this is how they reacted and
they're about to get burned
[Applause]
first off I couldn't put a character
like that in one of our sketches for
fear of being protested due to negative
stereotypes secondly that is absolutely
a fire hazard at bare minimum thirdly
that deal was the gateway to peace god
there were near Abbas line around the
country that was the quote the Gateway
to peace here we know the Gateway to
peace this deal listen this is that's
how you know they're the eddy Haskell's
of the world they had no intention of
ever honoring the deal they had no
intention of ever respecting they never
had respect for the United States or the
deal they were gliding to you taking
what they could get it's not like
someone all of a sudden right has a
flash of genius moment oh you know what
I want to work with the New Orlean it
seems like America isn't the bug the
flag doesn't happen overnight you were
always a dick okay that's just not the
throne computer into the buskin but we
made a similar kind of deal prior to
world war two with another German that's
true and that's King didn't work sorry
spend slash muskmelon trumpet president
Trump is being blast of course we're
being crazy and reckless well well maybe
you need to live maybe you need to be a
little bit crazy
maybe maybe crazier than the other guy
in some of these countries no president
Trump may not be let's let's even give
the argument to people who say may not
be a great man may not be a good guy
personally but how in the hell I've
heard people calling him a bully now how
in the hell can you paint a guy as a
bully who's pushing around the dictators
who starve and tortured her citizens and
perform forceful abortions call him at
the very least an antihero good world
you head for was grades yeah the version
with Trump you lose the moral high
ground when you commit forceful
abortions and starve your own people and
convince them that you can control their
mind and when you throw gays off
rooftops and when you have death for
apostasy you don't get to call somebody
else a bully and this is something very
new by the way for people they look back
and they see they see a UH Gary Oldman's
performs Winston Churchill yeah I was
not elected a big reason he was a prick
I know there other geopolitical read
everyone in but yeah people forget that
yeah but do you think Winston do you
think Churchill was a bully to Hitler
you think he was Great Santini throwing
me a little eight off the basketball
[Laughter]
honestly it doesn't matter if you it
doesn't matter if you're more effective
you cannot be the bull and this is the
problem the left just hates success the
left hey success they assume the
underdog has the moral high ground
whether it's Palestine whether it's at a
look at that voice crack call yourself
jack dumbass talking another show about
the squirt gun our only shot jelly egg I
can solve that problem for you
Merkel just came out just came to
complain that that Germany can't be
under the United States umbrella anymore
because there's no law it is no longer
such that the United States simply
protects us but the Europe must take its
destiny in its own hands that's the task
of the future this first German leader
telling Europe what it should do I
understand that it could throw up some
red flags just go with it but she's
making her problems like there's a [ __ ]
US when people talk about President
Donald Trump as a bully and we're
talking about the United States right
guess what there is no Germany or rain
deal there is no Ireland Iran deal we're
the only country that people are talking
about when they're talking about the
Iran deal why because we keep the free
world safe and we keep the rest of the
world in check we only care what Donald
Trump has to say about North Korea no
one gives a rat's ass what Angela Merkel
has I'll say about North Korea so you
know what I'm tired of caring what
anyone else thinks about how we handle
kim jeong-hoon the only person who could
possibly be inhibited by Kim jong-un
would maybe Justin Trudeau if you were
to take the average just the national
average male line up a hundred none of
them would be intimidated by kim
jeong-hoon
Oh Trudeau is a miracle because we keep
the freight when you want to know
countries have been defying the 2% NATO
minimum for years they've been ignoring
it the u.s. picks up the slack they pay
the bill for national defense we've been
paying for all these cut and they flit
and this is what bothers me you look I
did you Randy Lynn North Korea three
hostages gone look at her rain burning
the American flag and then next week
when we forget about this Germany's
gonna talk about how they provide free
health care refugee asylum and free
college oh yeah what's your Navy
it's a tugboat whistle izzi replica
hoping for a Boston Whaler from hoping
for a Boston Whaler thank you you're
welcome Germany and by the way were
making this point in the pitch meeting
yes baby beso
don't you have to understand is that
what we are to you is France to us or
friends to anyone not grief to anyone
that's what would happen you know you
would be France globally or like Greece
only you know with with National Defense
as you are economically to France
national screen that's you to us yes
it's the same situation yeah I'm getting
a little tired of providing peace for
the rest of the world and then being
vilified for it exactly and then paying
for it as well I mean countries as well
Japan we don't we provide like all
defense for Japan we provide all the
defense for it for everybody I mean
there was a study Sven was talking about
that they was at Russia could take over
a significant swath yeah I think it was
a 2016 state it was conducted by NATO
and came out that they wouldn't need 60
hours to take the bout to come so that's
like an extended weekend hours by the
way we take significantly less time for
the United States to take Canada yeah
eighty percent of their population with
a hundred miles of the US border they
have ten percent of the population of
the United States you know we would just
walk up to that border and say I mean
come on do you have Trudeau or the
fridge is that America is it Imperial
really I'm okay with a little
imperialism now how about how about
either we be an imperialist nation or
not or no just have nothing we don't
protect any other countries at that
point by the way people say well isn't
that a bit reductive what's wrong we had
this with Naomi well what's wrong with
being reductive when we're dealing with
people when we're dealing with countries
who without nuclear weapons commit most
violations of human rights killing
Christians Jews where's the middle
ground what's wrong with being reductive
saying they shouldn't be allowed to have
nukes and we won't do cop I'm not okay
with these countries having non safety
scissors much less any red button no
Israel shot down Iran's missiles no
casualties everyone gets mad at them
it's proof the left just absolutely
despise a success because they truly
believe that if you were an underdog you
automatically have the moral high ground
how in the world could you be upset
otherwise we're not we're not bombing
Iran we're just not doing business with
them
well that would be like evil that would
be like getting mad
you showed up for a Tupperware party you
find out that the lady is a Nazi who
just gassed a bunch of Jews and threw
some gays off a rooftop and said you
know what I'm not buying a three-piece
set and everyone you're a dick we're
just not gonna do this tell me where
parties are yelling - we're just gonna
put them in the corner I am so tired of
this it's constant it's constant Iran
was a moderate Muslim country in the 70s
and where we had we had Turkey we had
Egypt yeah that worked out liked it then
it was Morocco until all of a sudden
their Olympians refused to shake hands
with the Jews serene at the Olympics and
then we had Indonesia Malaysia record
church burned by we're not we're not
bombing them we're just saying we're not
gonna do business with you think about
Israel we talked about this with Israel
the left gets so furious at Israel when
you you talk about how it really
effectively has the current map that it
has today people show you look at all
the land they gained Syria Egypt Jordan
said let's wipe off Jews from the face
of the map exactly
I am absolutely amazed to me okay you
don't need to be an imperialist nation
right just going out taking over stuff
because it's 2018 but certainly in a
defensive war people want to wipe you
out and you win you take their stuff and
you move on down the trail North Korea
you should be grateful that we learnt
simply calling you the 51st state Iran
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do if we decide that we don't want you
anymore you know what I'm okay with out
at that point but if I read tomorrow
like the United States just drew dropped
in a mushroom cloud over around but you
know that's fine
70% of the day all parking 70% them are
okay with death for apostasy so yeah but
the 30 percent they shouldn't let it get
to 70 they shouldn't let it get to 70
you let it get to a majority or even a
poor Ally guess what you don't get to
sit at the adults table if the ghosts of
the kids table doesn't mean we're gonna
kill all of you but we're certainly not
gonna do commerce with you or treat you
as equals or try and appease you for
peace you burning the flag I'm burning
the American flag anti-freedom
anti anything that isn't your sick
twisted demented Muslim way of life
pieces of there's a little have been
Shapiro after this
there we go keep clicking
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm back in the panties again good for
the SunShot all right when do be cause
they'll be swollen balls some call me a
queen comfort or where the quality's
good light and the pressures just right
back in the babies again Ranger panties
available nada with crush opcom get
yours today
it's like tea bagging an agent in that
list of this
[Music]
because I know it'll anger him more
right for coming in the break I don't
want be here I hate you so angry Ben is
always a fun been glad to have our first
guest you know him of course host of the
ben shapiro show on The Daily wire now
nationally syndicated you can follow him
at two pencha Piro so he can take it out
on you and not just me
Ben why are you such why you such an
angry Jew today God dang it who booked
this why am I even here oh god not
Crowder this stays long enough what's
what you know rough with your day you
look like you've done a lot of percocet
there's a glass and your honor yeah it's
just it's been a long day man it's been
a long day I can't even talk about some
of this stuff on the air I mean I killed
a guy that's my thing I probably
shouldn't have said on the air yeah
smart guy you let that one slip pretty
quickly yeah the fit a little Danish
this is why my lawyer says I shouldn't
talk to the tops but now that's already
out there case why you like president
Trump I will go talk to Robert Muller
just as much as I please okay very much
so is it is it just personal stuff is it
stuff that's going on the news it has
you so pissed off oh no it's a the news
is it the news is fine
I mean honestly like the news is the
news is better than fine I like the
president Trump is doing excellent
things on the foreign policy front which
is which is great he has he has this
interesting view of the world President
Trump where everybody is winner or loser
yeah and that doesn't work well in
economics because there can be mutual
winners when you and I are trading
products and services but it does work
really well on foreign policy it turns
out because it turns out that if Iran
loses everybody wins
yes that's been that's been really good
I just got done sent right before this
what's wrong with me I said people often
say well that's reductive well what's
wrong with being reductive with a nation
that commits gross violations of human
rights when they don't have a nuclear
arsenal
there is no middle ground again this is
the part that's hilarious to me is
everybody like well you know that Iran
nuclear deal was preventing them from
getting a nuclear weapon and those
moderates they were really being
involved in by the nuclear deal said
well you know what if they want to be
moderate you know what they could do
they could just give up their nuclear
weapons without it's exact to stop
funding terrorism in fact I did I did an
entire piece on this yesterday at my
website daily where where we talked
specifically about the I'm sorry about
that but you know just cuz we're wildly
more successful than anything else that
is absolutely true there's no doubt
about it because you employ slave labor
it's amazing what you do with children
at computers in Bengal
well I mean you're wondering why I had a
bad day our contract just got tossed I'm
sorry but in any case they've been but
one of the one of the things I was
saying is that they're only a couple of
nations in human history that have had
nuclear weapons or we're developing
nuclear weapons and gave them up one was
1993 South Africa gave up their nukes
yeah and the other was in 2003 Qaddafi
gave up his incipient nuclear program
both of them did so as a show of good
faith to the world it wasn't that we
came along and said here's a bunch of
money now will you give up their nukes
because that would be stupid then they
would just say well I'll keep the money
and develop my nukes right instead it
was a bunch of regimes attempting to
moderate themselves first and then as a
symptom of that moderation they were
saying here's our nukes
so trying to say that Iran was going to
moderate because we gave them a bunch of
cash is stupid if they wanted to
moderate and have a bunch of cash they
could do so without any agreement at all
right well it's it's it you know
compares would be a plea plea bargain 10
about South Africa every time a Qaddafi
versus sort of Kramer vs Kramer Dustin
Hoffman with the Kimmy ice cream tub
just saying don't you do it don't you do
it that's the big difference there is a
big difference one occurred before and
one occurred after you think like I just
talked about nuking them we're not
bombing them we're just not going to do
business with them we're just gonna
isolate them I mean even liberal parents
just makes their kid have a timeout or
put them in the corner or not even
spanking them and let's be real about
this it is providing Israel the option
to spank them which i think is a good
option it's proved it's providing this
newfound alliance of Israel Saudi Arabia
Egypt Jordan UAE
the capacity to actually fight back
against Iranian aggression because what
the Iran deal really did mostly was it
said to any of those nations if you do
anything against Iran you're in breach
of this agreement you've destroyed world
peace by trump saying listen this
agreements no longer here then it
becomes very clear who are the violators
of the the peace in the Middle East and
that was obvious for anybody who had
half a brain anyway since Iran has taken
over Syria they've now taken over
Lebanon
they've taken over most of Iraq they've
taken over they've taken over Yemen
they've taken over the Gaza Strip - I
mean for the amount of funding they're
giving the Hamas like what exactly like
why was this controversial in the first
place I will say - Obama's credit it was
Barack Obama who created the Alliance of
Saudi Arabia Egypt Jordan Israel in the
UAE he did so completely unintentionally
just like every other good thing he
didn't intentionally but this was mostly
Obama's doing because by kissing
Iran's ass he put everybody else in a
position where they had to suddenly ally
with each other in order to face down
right yeah but you know that's very
temporary and if
look back and something happens no one's
gonna blame the alliance that you just
mentioned they're just gonna blame the
Jews they're wondering why I'm having a
bad day every day is to blame the Jew
days we're just talking about that when
you're talking about you're talking
about obviously the listen Israel gave
up Lane and defensive war this is where
people talk about our European us I'm
not paid by the Jews that would take the
money and I would talk about big Jew
money but when you talk about Syria
Jordan Egypt and they said we're gonna
wipe him off for being Jews I'm amazing
you didn't just take all their stuff but
my point is in the realm of history to
look back and listen let's be honest do
we really think that Saudi Arabia and
Israel are gonna be allies for a long
time no I think Jews could be left
holding the bag long term which is
always what worries me with these
temporary alliances they never last with
Islamic countries I mean I think that's
true but I also think that this is the
best position Israel has been in its
entire history insofar as they're now a
bunch of states that are suddenly saying
you're our allies are not our enemies I
mean the Saudi Arabian leader Mohammed
bin Sultan literally said to the
Palestinian leadership take the deal
that's on the table or sit down and shut
up
that's amazing amazing thing and it also
demonstrates by the way how a lot of
these countries were using the
Palestinians as pawns for so long
because they obviously don't care about
enough and they don't care about the
stuff enough to actually abide by their
previous principles it was always a ruse
it was always we're gonna use this as a
club against the Jews well now it turns
out we need to use the Jews to club
against the Iranians so that goes
immediately by the wayside well that's
my point pragmatically they're in the
best place that they've been in a while
but doesn't it make you a little bit
leery just to trust someone with the
name Mohammed
well no not necessary
Israelis are named Mohammed probably not
many that's a weird question they're not
a lot of Jewish Israelis named Jesus
either this is drew no I'm just saying
I'm just saying they're in a good place
right now
I just I'm always very tempermental but
but for that for the Jews now is good
yeah okay what you think now if I could
have just taken now like throughout
human history now had been fine yes
because it turns out that now is usually
us getting killed as long as we're not
being killed and they're a bunch of like
temporary alliances turns out better
than no alliances at all friends better
than people attempts gonna kill you so
I'll take it you know I'm not exactly
next stop LOD Costanza
across the Middle East but you know
you'll take it you take the W at this
point that's today's lesson take the W
when you can take it um you know it's
funny that you mention this good versus
bad and kind of on the world stage that
being said in economics let's kind of
get rid of the tariffs and stuff which
we agree on um the the tax cut though is
remarkably popular so when you combine
that with this with foreign policy and
Iran just did us a favor by burning the
American flag in their in their
government there after the deal was
ripped up okay maybe you were Eddie
Haskell in it and you never this wasn't
exactly the the portal to peace do you
think this spells potentially
re-election for Donald Trump tax cuts if
it were just policy then the answer
would be clearly yes right I mean 57% of
Americans now say that the country is
moving in the right direction it's
almost impossible to see a situation
where somebody does not win reelection
under those circumstances the economy
continues to boom the tax cuts are very
popular the the regulatory cuts are
having a solid impact on businesses he's
seeing success in his North Korean
negotiations so far he's seeing a
success in in in creating this this
Saudi egyptian-israeli toward any
alliance all of this stuff is really
really good okay and so on policy it's
very hard to argue with the results that
president Trump's administration has
been getting the real question is going
to be every election is between two
people and unfortunately Donald Trump
still is the guy right and so the the
question is going to be when it comes to
2020 and you see a lot of Donald Trump
being Donald Trump are people in your to
it which could actually help him or are
people going to be you know shocked all
anew when it turns out that there's
somebody on the other side who is not
the worst candidate in American history
like I yeah I I think that there's a
solid chance Democrats will pick
somebody garbage me for 2020 because
they're just so many go who do you think
is the likely picker if you're narrow it
down to a field of three to five if you
were to say three to five I would
probably say Kamala Harris for the
intersectionality of an odd Joe Joe
Biden for the for the you know Obama and
the and the stasis and back to normalcy
you know campaign and maybe Elizabeth
Warren from the Bernie wing almost
Bernie runs again which was you good I
mean at this point there are no upper
age limits the presidency of the United
States I mean the skeletons from from
Holy Grail are actually filing for super
PAC approval yes yes I love how Matt
Damon is no longer bitching about the
actuary tables if Bernie Sanders
all of a sudden it's All Quiet on the
Dayman front okay well we have we have
an unbelievable so of course we decided
on Moscow wave Ryan Bader we have Blair
white we have Ellen Benjamin let me
assist you just mentioned North Korea um
that's also a big plus this week it like
I said big stress a little disappointed
when President Trump afterwards said he
was great to these three people it's
like oh just just take take the ball and
leave but it is it is a victory listen I
mean it seems like right yet no question
yeah
there's no question that's a victory it
is it is to the point where Trump says
that sort of stuff we're like our
capacity for outrage is now gone because
like okay so Trump said something real
dumb shocker
Wow he said they were treated real nice
by North Korea like that's because he
says that kind of said I'm sure that
everything is magnificent everything is
the best everything is really nice okay
we get it like but here's the bottom
line those three guys are standing on
the tarmac with Trump and Trump made
that happen and Obama did not make that
happen so that is a that is a point in
trumps favor now the real question is
gonna be what happens in June right so
there are a couple of possibilities with
what's gonna happen in June you know is
this going to be a situation where Trump
kind of bends over backwards because he
feels like he's been given some goodies
by the North Koreans or is this a
situation where they're looking to come
to the table not because they love
President Trump are scared by President
Trump but because their nuclear mountain
just imploded in North Korea the fact is
that they had a testing site and that
site completely degraded it completely
fell apart and immediately they started
talking with South Koreans so it's quite
possible that Trump could have just
become like the luckiest president ever
right it's suddenly their nuclear
program just Universal unilaterally
combusted it just randomly exploded and
Trump's like wow look what I did
yeah that's fine with me I mean sure
good he's like a Chauncey Gardner who
just walked into the right place at the
right time in North Korea is Dom DeLuise
just running through with a set from
Blazing Saddles comes down like oh damn
yeah we'll talk now which is why it's so
remarkable to me that Justin Trudeau got
scared down by this guy that just you
could take a sample size of any country
oh you know what I'll even throw I'll
even throw a Saudi Arabia to the mix and
you would not find a man intimidated by
it by by Kim jong-eun Justin Trudeau
Trudeau is a marvel because he for some
reason played ball yeah that dude is
intimidated by like a table like a
butter knife I mean it was really judge
Justin Trudeau has has about as much
intimidation factor as like Lena Dunham
clothes like there's just not there's
not a lot of intimidation factor there
let me ask you this because
I know you're not a big fan of Trump
personality-wise but you're on you have
to be on a deserted island okay
president Donald Trump or prime minister
Justin Trudeau on a desert island yeah
well I mean wow that's the so you
thought you're having a rough day yeah
the reason I the only reason I'd say
Trudeau is because you could take all of
his stuff and leave him to die in your
Coconut Beach right exactly like it's
just the two of us and it's up to
survival like I feel like Trump's and
Trump big but he's I think a scrappy
fighter so yeah and he's got about a
hundred pounds on me and a lot of a lot
of interior rage so yes you know III
doubt I doubt my own capacity against
President Trump stuck on a desert island
do not get between that man and what he
wants Justin Trudeau have whereas you
just say was stared down by kim jong
hood so yeah i feel i have a slightly
better shot with with with it like i
could appeal to his feminine side or
somesuch
yes exactly or you could challenge him
to a pull up contest and then when he
loses just force him to be your
indentured servant I know he's he's he's
ripped it means one of these guys know
he's skinny fat he is he has the body of
a pregnant woman without the bump it is
it is absolutely a shame I forgot I was
talking to I forgot I was talking to mr.
Atlas over here Stephen yes Charles
Atlas that's because that's because
someone kicked sand in my face and then
I did the isometrics that I bought in
the back of a comic book but you're
pretty you're a pull-up machine CrossFit
pull-up machinery did you say you could
do some like that's exactly 49 bench
just CrossFit yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
cannot get about 40 pull-ups in a row
Kip ups but that's still impressive but
still very very different dynamic but
listen it is it is absolutely very
impressive and I don't know because a
lot of people don't know that about you
all right
people can of course watch the ben
shapiro show at the daily why it won't
show through your suit been for a smart
guess why I'm doing ad choices
verifiable my friend why do you think
how many how many marketers indicated to
now on radio says yeah so the the
podcast is now syndicated to I believe
40-plus markets and we are in five there
are six of the top ten so that's really
exciting
absolutely it's fantastic and he's part
of the Westwood one podcast network
which you know our free show on
Thursdays we're with them now too so see
some newspapers pretty soon mr. Ben
Shapiro at Ben Shapiro thanks so much
for being here I'm sorry you were having
a bad day hopefully
made a little bit worse oh you made me
feel so much better Stephen who broke
this thing yes
Blair white after this oh it's about
that time when the show were human boys
should do delivery from our club buddy
today yeah but you're just gonna exploit
old Harper a lot of was crowded out
comes her smokes up it's only $99 for
people or 69 for students veterans
active military and a bunch if they know
that it's used to fix my leg and buy me
all the cheese's so they wouldn't have
any problem joining but some people
maybe some people know and they don't
care I'm so tired of people who don't
care and don't turn it thought it was
calling spongebob I'm so tired
what's wrong
[Music]
Thank You mr. Shapiro I'm glad to have
our next guest I don't know that we've
spoken since since well you can follow
up follow on the Twitter Matt miss Blair
white MS Blair white she doesn't have MS
Miss and Miss Blair white I know
sometimes people get that wrong uh and
of course miss Blair white on the
Instagram Blair have you been on the
show since we last since I we were last
on Rogan kind of talking about you and
my mom and all that I don't think so I
think the last time I saw you was the
Christmas special and then we were gonna
do something else for the Oscars but my
scheduling was messed up but it's been a
minute yeah yes this is true yes we were
talking about how my mother was not
super familiar with the with the
transgender community and with the
language barrier she was incredibly
confused really she's a sweetheart but
she was miscommunications abound and she
is an absolute sweetheart now Blair um
we don't have a ton of time because we
got this we all must come we got Ryan
Bader oh my god we have such a big show
today but I do know this I was actually
just following this recently I know what
brought you to mind so drag Cohn is a
thing and it's like it's it's a it's
sort of like comic-con for I don't know
if the term drag queen is derogatory but
I know you're not gonna care so much
because they've all threatened to kill
you if you attend am I mistaken yeah so
it's RuPaul's Drag Con it's here in LA
and it's kind of like a big LGBTQ
convention based on the show RuPaul's
Drag Race and kind of everyone in LA
goes yeah and they invited me to go and
wanted to give me like a talent pass VIP
to do the red carpet all that stuff and
people have absolutely like lost their
minds I've gotten so many threats of
violence of worse than violence it's
it's just a saying from well because
RuPaul got in trouble remember for using
the word [ __ ] this is RuPaul the cause
RuPaul isn't most drag queens actually
aren't very politically correct because
sure you know their messes they're in
costume right yes I wonder why you might
not curry their favor um so what's this
are you still going oh oh yeah I'm going
I'm going
I have friends flying in town that are
coming with me I'm gonna have security
and stuff
I really don't care I feel like it's
kind of it comes with the territory of
what I do at this point you get threats
like that yeah and I tend to stand on
principle I'm just gonna go I really
don't care let me ask you this because
we've talked about this before there you
know there's there's for people who
don't know there's obviously
transvestites drag queens and there's
transsexuals and then there's
transgender and and some people like
yourself trans centers have gone through
multiple procedures and some people are
basically just drag queens who call
themselves transgenders it's how do we
at drag con is this mostly just men who
dress up like women or is it become a
hotbed for the transgender community as
well honey every hot mess [ __ ] la it's
just like a big LGBTQ thing it's based
around drag queens which are just
performers but everyone on the spectrum
goes to this thing so be interesting
it's not really my Shan rrah
people aren't gonna be super friendly to
me there but our most drag queens like
are they are they gay are they
interested what is what is the what is
the deal gay men
there are some I went to a show at one
time and there was a female jock weaned
just a biological woman just dressed up
kind of extra some extra some extra red
tape and some hair dye I mean what do
you do yes everything's so arbitrary you
know I feel like none of it makes sense
anymore and you know the biological
female drag queens though are usually a
message like they're really untalented
just I don't really like okay this begs
a question I don't mean to be an ass
sure what would what would be considered
talent like for a drag queen like are we
talking like direct like fire-breathing
dragons are they doing are they doing
magic tricks I mean the only drag queen
ever said there are really some crazy
ones I've seen some beyond like still
coming out like ten feet tall there's
probably fire-breathing ones I don't
know usually the talent is limited but
there's those small occasions or it's
like they're doing something first the
the stilt walking they're like how could
I take with some next-level let's know
God or was it like I don't know or it's
a very it's a very but I feel like this
has brought people like you and myself
closer together because I was confused
and then at one point like transgenders
like well you shouldn't be so confused
and now
look at the rulebook I'm a little more
confused and now I have more people
going I'm confused too
because I don't I don't you know listen
always beg some questions
the only drag queen I ever met you
remember this mm-hm was that a my wife
had the bread idea at a Valentine's date
to go to a a burlesque show and there
was one very large like Samoan drag
queen and he just walked out and
beelined for me like a laser beam and I
was like no just move just move along
down the trauma this guy had no talent
this guy just put on some tassels and
walked over and was like the Buffalo
Bill from Silence of the Lambs he was
doing this right by my table and I was
like listen you're gonna do some
stand-up you're gonna do some improv and
I like the chicks there he would have
had to get pretty darn close to you me
get some contact yes but he got the big
the biggest cheers some of the some of
the chicks there I had to get pretty
close too yeah not a lot of it was a
land with a shallow talent pool air this
is the main point you know no this guy
didn't sing I think he just lit mild
words to a song and that was it and got
all these cheers like what you're
cheering for nothing he's done nothing
you've also gotten death threats from
from vegans and vegetarians which I have
as well because I had lierre keith on
because you're no longer a vegan so
you're getting it from all sides player
getting it from every end very much that
yeah I made a video about being vegan I
was vegan for about ten years and I feel
like if you like me vegans probably like
good for like a two week cleanse cycle
but once you've hit that like decade
mark I think things start declining and
my house took a definite dip I was
deficient in so many things I said okay
screw it I'm done doing this I thought
when he was just habit anyways so I was
like okay I'm just gonna change my diet
made a video about it and I feel like I
was very polite yeah usually I'm not but
I was in that not always very nice and
there was just dozens and dozens and
dozens of response videos of people just
losing their minds over it okay so uh
what what would our what's your status
now it's the vegans you are you who are
you more afraid of is it like is it an
angry drag queen slash vegan chain gang
is it an alliance at this point let's
see
every group that hates me uh vegans jock
Queens trans people black lives matter
Islam that one has to be quiet because
they could here you know I just did a
debate for the dear Chuck yeah that'll
be out soon yes honestly as far as I'm
concerned all the right groups hate me
yes the Muslims you got loca for but I
mean that the vegans they don't have
energy to carry out anything no they
don't they don't have that they don't
have their cynical endurance yes yeah
they can type but they can't chase you
right exactly
well you know it that's actually good
you would probably much more on top of
your health because you see doctors
regularly obviously with your we know
when you're doing hormones and anything
like that I mean mainly we're doing
eight aging men you go through the
hormone replacement therapy these are
people would be more on top of this than
people who just released some YouTube
videos and what bothers me listen people
can be healthy and be vegans but there
is a lot of bad health advice coming
from the vegan community and it's
dogmatic and and yeah we had Lyra Keith
on was a former vegan remember on the
show we got so many death threats I felt
bad for Lee err who was a liberal on the
show because but she became more
conservative because of a death threat
she got from the angry vegans so becomes
a doctor a nutritionist when in reality
the reason I stopped being vegan was
because I went to a doctor right you
know everyone thinks they're an expert
on it and it really is like a religion
yeah well I stopped doing green
smoothies because I went to a doctor my
uh you know my thyroid got real because
if you do a lot of raw greens
particularly have a thyroid issue the
oxalates and the greens it's actually
really rough on your thyroid so my
doctor just said he's like listen and
he's super and I also go to a place was
just preventive care where these doctors
really do a scan every year to check you
for cancer to check your overall health
that's I highly recommend everybody do
that to some degree and they just said
listen the truth is cook your vegetables
like so yeah the perfect thing would be
to have your meat whatever your your
your complex carbohydrate is in a
limited amount and if you could steam
your vegetables like that's great but
raw vegetables we know some people don't
react to them well that's all and the
problem was fixed my blood work got
better final question
boy scout issue have been following that
this week what do you think about girls
and the Boy Scouts oh my god it was so
they what they did was they changed the
name of the Boy Scout to what was at
Scouts BSA or something yes yes um PSM
yeah I mean I'm of the opinion there
have been many many studies to
corroborate it that young boys and girls
do quite well developmentally when they
are you know involved in activities with
just their gender so right it's really
not something that I'm before did the
Girl Scouts chants or names to you or is
the Girl Scouts aren't happy about it
and I'm asking this because I think
transgenders are a lot in the either the
Boy Scouts the voice or the Girl Scouts
are both as a transgender person but you
obviously have strong opinions on
transitioning children what's your
opinion on Girl Scouts they're being
like well listen we want a girl only
space period it seems to me like that's
a reasonable request because boys are
gross it is reasonable it's boys are
gross
it's such a conundrum because obviously
one of the things I've been very
outspoken about is that I'm against
children transitioning yeah the fact
that I'm against it doesn't change the
fact that they're there and so it does
it makes you sad that young kids can't
participate in stuff but at the same
time I think when you're at that young
age I think it is better just to stick
with the biological sex and like if
you've been transitioning since you were
like six I disagree with that so happily
by the time you're 13 if you want to
join some kind of thing maybe you've
never developed puberty of your
biological sex but well that doesn't
happen even if you're not transgender if
you're in the Boy Scouts when you're 13
it's it halts puberty it's effectively
an alternative to puberty blockers when
you're closer when you're only a couple
of years away from the draft age listen
whittling in the woods with a [ __ ]
bracelet that's not quite cutting it
okay it is Ms blue-eyed miss Blair white
want to make sure people get that right
also on Instagram Blair I am going to be
watching for videos from its course
youtube.com slash Blair White X sorry I
forgot that one with drag Cohn keep us
updated thank you so much for coming in
thank you so much for having me bye guys
okay we'll have Ryan Bader after this
fighting
[Music]
the Nature Network marry my Jasper
pung-ho the male silverback : a pure
picture of power speed and a package of
elegance you know what I swear that
gorilla reminds me of my old college
roommate that's it son cannon damage a
spur just do the lines
no really it'd be great if we could do
like a side-by-side and just bring in
don't say it don't say what the name of
your roommate just Dodge drop a move on
come on no no it's nothing bad he was a
great roommate and he was built like a
brick outhouse it's just the resemblance
here is striking between this gorilla am
don't now don't what don't don't say the
name Jasper
my roommate Tyrone Jasper
[Music]
[Music]
all right you're sure that I have some
moves so the next guy doesn't kick my
ass I always get a little bit nervous
when we have guests who don't you know
obviously we have a lot of MMA fighters
in the show but they're friends of the
show it's true hey leaning more
politically you never know if they're
comfortable he is a black rifle coffee
shirt so I don't think is gonna be that
offended at the kind of content on the
show oh I have fought him for a while
you can follow him on the Instagram and
the Twitter at Ryan Bader mr. Bader
thank you for being here sir oh thanks
for having me
I am super glad to have you look at this
now you are you are you just standing
there to make your arm look bigger than
this over here exactly
people don't know you were fighting
Saturday the 12th in San Jose against
King mo there's a Bellator tournament
people who follow the show should know
for the heavyweight champion of Bellator
there's failure we've had Matt matryona
I got a chill on and and you're fighting
King mo I don't think in this tournament
you would have liked heavyweight for a
long time I did self-proclaimed King you
know fighting Muhammad the wall you know
I'm light heavyweight champ I defended
it so I felt like I did feel like I
needed to defend that belt before moving
into the heavyweight division yeah I'm
so I did that and I was told you know
hey you can keep your light heavyweight
belt but would you be interested in
doing a heavyweight tournament Grand
Prix style tournament without knowing
any of the guys well if it was one night
it was over time you know and we said
yes let's do it you know I wanted to
fight heavyweight I want to you know try
to get it be a two division champion
that's not done a lot in mixed martial
arts and so for me it was a no-brainer
it's done even less at the higher weight
classes you know difference between 155
and 170 you know is very very different
from 205 to 265 but yeah any any night
he didn't even know the person I would
have liked that I have a bronchial
infection I know can we do modified
rules this I mean woody what are you
walking around at now right I'm about
230 right now and so I don't have to cut
weight this week which is a big plus for
me it it pulls that stress of me doing
an interview with you right now I would
be thinking about I need to cut 15
pounds out of my body right by tomorrow
morning right yes and and I'm excited to
see how I feel without having to take
that out yeah
got to do something to you performance
right and so on you know I'm fine mo
he's probably the smallest guy I've ever
fought you know but in this tournament I
go out there and win I'm treating on
fight mat meet your own who I know he's
a friend of mine he's friend of yours
you know and yeah he he's a big dude
that's why I'm jumping into the
heavyweight tournament yes exactly well
ya can't self-professed king yeah and
then we have member King mo got in
trouble for having an oxygen inhaler in
his corner one time which I just thought
was funny it was like of all the
performance-enhancing drugs he got pop
those taking an oxygen which they found
out later I don't even think works but
I'm glad to hear that you think your
performance will be better not so sure
after appearing on this show this sucks
your soul right out of your actually I
think we're a good luck charm I don't
think I think everyone who has but
peered in the show is won their fight
afterward
chills well make that one she'll won he
beat Wanderlei uh I don't remember Jake
Shields next fight who's that from there
I'm from Brooklyn I think enough from
Brooklyn yeah I have no idea here
talking about George st. Pierre beat
Michael Bisping so you know what you're
welcome yeah I'll have I'll keep a nice
shelf here for the belt you know you and
King mo have a history going back into
college right yeah you know we I was
he's older than me you know about three
or four years old older than me that I
was a freshman at Arizona State
University I went out there and you know
my my corner man were Aaron Simpson fine
you go see another guy named Eric Larkin
that it's a big big time national
champion wrestler sure they knew who I
was facing I didn't really know I walked
out there and this dude jumped and he
literally jumped over my head and I
turned around and look at my cornermen
and they're just cracking up laughing
you know and then I went out there and
he proceeded to tech me which means they
beat me by 15 points or more basically
the worst thing that could happen it's
pretty right yeah terrible and so now
you know the 16 8 17 18 years later I'm
still competing he's still competing and
I get to get that back you know I get to
go out there and redeem myself and I've
done that a few times I've wrestled Phil
Davis in college he ended up being me a
close match and then I end up beat him
into mixed martial arts fights so I buy
I think this is an ultimate competition
right well I mean you're a lot bigger
than him now so it's like you're a late
bloomer
you're an angry late bloomer Bob speak I
have a question for you and I don't want
this to be a sore spot but obviously is
in the news everywhere
you fought John Jones and he won that
encounter I figured your segue because
you lost to the King mo I think it was a
perfect time to enter with something I'm
sure and now they seem to be throwing
the book at him the guy's popped hot now
so many times do you think that changes
his legacy well what's what's your
opinion on that having fought John Jones
because it's not a one-time offense I
mean this is yeah you can't get it back
together yeah I mean listen he's
probably one of the best fighters of all
time yes with you know physical specimen
his talent is off the charts you know
and he's never lost a fight technically
he got DQ'd when you know what fight but
yeah he's never actually lost a fight
yeah I do think it's gonna tarnish his
legacy he's been it wasn't a one-time
thing it's been multiple multiple things
some plus he's he's he's been out for a
while and you know that allowed I got a
Cormier to come in and take over that
take over a spot exactly and Cormier is
a good guy now you know and yeah you
know so that definitely tarnished your
legacy for sure if there's a one you
know one-time mistake everybody makes
mistakes you talk it up alright hey guys
I'm sorry but then you come back and
something else happens yeah it's to the
point with the latest thing it's it's
almost like you can't be well he hit
let's be clear again right yes the first
act was hitting a pregnant lady well hi
and then running and then several tests
positive afterward and these positive
tests came after being a motivational
speaker two kids that I cleaned up my
life but you you pop hot three times
from now wait for reparations you know
you see yes yeah you see you see this a
lot though Ryan we're and we've had
fighters in this show talked about it
were you know the defense to from a lot
of these guys I know that Jonna said it
says well the majority of athletes are
honest and so it really doesn't affect
the legacy encounters of people like
George st. Pierre who never tested
positive what would you say what would
you say to those people is that true do
you think a majority or plurality of
people are using something or do you
think we're at the point where it
doesn't really matter that even the
playing field is even you know
especially in the UFC that's I mean you
seen performance you seen bodies change
you know yes
it's crazy you have one guy that's
totally ripped out weigh-ins he's an
animal and then I not fought these guys
- and then you get in the cage with them
when you saw - came and it's been a year
maybe and they're not taking their stuff
and maybe it's not really doing anything
physically to him but mentally up here
they're they're not on it anymore and so
uh you know for me I remember one fight
in particular I was I was going out
there the guy pet you know caught before
and got caught whatnot and I remember
going in there and just breaking him in
like you didn't have any spirit fight
left you know and so this is an anti
testing you mean
yeah after testing started so in in this
in UFC with the you stata testing I do
believe it's cut down tremendously
yes no but ended in the early days I've
come on yeah in the early I mean listen
I don't want to name names but vittor
Belfort was fighting a heavyweight now I
can barely keep the middleweight scale
the guy was walking at 220 with like
like veins and his nipples for crying
out loud so it really isn't say in the
early days now they're both different
opinions on that well hopefully listen
we wish you the best with this fight sir
sorry we just had b-roll of you teaching
how to stuff a double leg takedown naked
I wish I could have talked about it more
but you look good Ryan so breezy no
testing or not that was a video that I'm
sure will get a lot of feedback from the
female fans people can follow you at
Ryan Bader and where can they tune in to
watch this fight so it's going to be on
paramount Network it was the old Spike
TV it's a 6 p.m. Pacific Standard Time
and great card and then we're gonna cap
it off be the main event and the winners
moving on to fight a dmitriy own and I'm
going to you know throw my hat in there
to be a to division champion and go out
there and win this whole tournament
well I can't watch if it's between you
jail or Mitrione I just I'll just sit on
the sidelines
I can't well it's funny if Matt and I
are friends ooh you know and he texts me
he's okay can't wait to punch you in the
face in October that's something I hope
that relationship is good we have to go
at Ryan Bader we wish you luck sir we'll
talk with you against these guys yeah
[Music]
every day comedians like Stephen and
Jared here just want to make you smile
and spank computer he just needs to have
the electric bills paid he's a computer
for God's sake these boys need your help
they don't have a big budget
unlike Jimmy Kimmel who still manages to
suck
do the right thing hi I am lesbian Sarah
McLaughlin for $99 a year you can join
the mug club and keep the lights on and
keep the comedy going cuz if you don't I
will euthanize these people I'll put
them down like the animals they are
don't think I won't I'm a lesbian
I'm crazy
[Music]
[Music]
turns out the backstroke only works if
you're on top of the water
I just drown our sound guy if you're in
the water you just die breath stroke
side stroke fancy diving - backstroke no
you just die you have to be on top of
the why didn't know this because the
butterfly stroke not the information I
thought I learned I don't know how
Phelps does it but thank you so much -
of course
Elon Musk Ben Shapiro Ryan Bader Blair
white unbelievable or have Owen Benjamin
we hope he doesn't euthanize this no we
don't believe a week next week you know
I was like 23 years old before I
realized that people talk about
euthanasia
they weren't just bitching about kids
and Nike shoe so much shots I'm not
gonna lie about but I thought that - I'm
like why is everyone just let the kids
be kids I thought that let them be
so what out there Asian I thought that
when I got in college to be fair when I
got into I was 16 because I was a high
five years awesome works but I got there
it was one of those things where we were
having a discussion in humanities class
we were talking about euthanasia and the
wave came over or the context hit me and
I realized there was I had no idea yeah
I had a friend who's doing a report on
the euthanasia I'm like that's boring as
hell yeah euthanasia it sucks in thesis
thesis but I like their pokey sticks
when I have one Chinese friend who has
it in his lunchbox that's pretty cool I
don't know I had a lot of Asian friends
well we were actually it's funny
incident anywhere was the Asians only
hung out with Asians almost and then the
Middle Eastern Muslims almost
exclusively hung out with Middle Eastern
Muslims and but they all they hated the
Jews so that was that was their kind of
that was their common bond but it was R
it was funny yes that was that was that
was that was wow they were they referred
to me until I found that it wasn't
Jewish um no I remember that though it's
very different from here even in the
United States know you have
neighborhoods really they [ __ ] about
segregation but then in places like
Montreal where it's not a melting pot
you may have people all in the same
school but they are completely self
segregated yeah yeah it was it was very
very rare to see an Asian a Chinese girl
or a Korean girl we didn't have a ton
but we had some Chinese I don't think
that any Japanese people at our school
we had a lot of Chinese people and we
had quite a few Koreans
I don't think eyes Menem it I don't
think I can ever remember any of them
being with a guy who was not new house
Asians fair
the Haitians yeah French Canadians hate
them because they're racist as hell yeah
because they speak French a lot of
Haitians came over there I didn't have
them in my school because I was in an
English school at that point and we had
very very few black slaves I just wanted
to point out the racism oh yeah the
racism of French Canada didn't you hear
it doesn't exist outside the United
States the United States entry in 20 we
invented it we invented slavery up the
world and melanin you were making a
point here during this right before we
came back with the drowning dance about
you know earlier we were talking about
why do we care what countries think and
easily I'm not saying that that is
necessarily the fulcrum as to how we're
going to dictate foreign policy I I'm
not saying it well water we can know of
course you could take things into
consideration but it is a genuine
question why do we care so much I think
and I think we're learning a lesson
right now with the US and the nations in
the world as a whole but I think you
know a mark of maturity in your own
personal life is just figuring out which
opinions matter which ones do not yeah
which people do you owe something to
which people do your best to and what's
people they don't oh I don't know
anything to know yeah they don't deserve
a part of me if I if I can throw them a
bone that I will right wink wink Iran I
appreciate by the way you said keep my
best and you pointed to me this he said
he was going to give a part of a snake
no it's a good point being able to
determine who you owe and who you don't
because that's one thing to a lot of
you'll have some people you have that do
what feels good you don't know anyone
anything well that's not true and by the
way the Obama thing that you didn't
build that that out that of course is
infuriating but as individualist we also
there is no self-made man there are
always other people have helped them
whether it's a wife whether it's
employees whether it's a team of whether
it's someone who encouraged him whether
it's a mentor I understand that
absolutely and you do owe that person
something if only it's respect sometimes
you know someone respects sometimes you
owe them a debt of gratitude right and
that's part of being an adult mister now
who you owe and who you don't but you
don't know the whole world people you
don't know any there's a lot of people
that you do not owe a figures they're
not going to your door does it mean you
have to open it a good example we oh we
oh everyone is we owe you
we do owe you for tuning in I've always
felt as though we owe
now we don't owe you doing exactly what
you request every single day but we do
owe you is doing this program to the
best of our abilities absolutely that's
why you see we don't rest on our laurels
and we try to constantly do something
new innovate that Glengarry Glen Ross
intro was extremely difficult to shoot
we had the call inaudible because we
couldn't get an office we constantly are
trying to like we see every single
performance re-earn your approval
but this also flies in the face and this
is something too I had a lot of
questions with Mark Driscoll on the show
this week for people who aren't mug Club
members mark driscoll we had Naomi Wolf
some some great guests for people who
have not yet joined and I know if you're
in hitting a notification bill and not
receiving them really the only way at
this point is to join one club if you
bookmark this page you're using Google
Chrome good luck it's gonna be replace
with CNN pretty soon
something else too you know this idea of
of you don't owe the world anything you
don't owe anybody anything this idea to
a lot of people asked I asked a question
with Mark Driscoll how do you balance
being authentic we were talking about
this as a Christian how do you balance
being authentic with still also trying
to be a good witness still also trying
to be a productive example right because
you have some people who are pious they
just act like you've never done anything
wrong yeah it doesn't help anybody at
all
I always felt ostracized from the church
as a kid because of people like that
because they'd hear me and they said
well he said a bad word I'd like yeah
but you forced your girlfriend to have
an abortion the pageant doesn't know
about it
you're far worse than me saying the S
word and there just happened to be in
youth Cabrera always had this sense of
kind of justice so I would get really
mad at that people who try to hide all
of their their mistakes their misdeeds
but then you have this message now that
everyone should just take pride in it
because you don't know anyone anything
and how do you balance that you know I
think it was I came from who I was I
don't know if it was pink I don't know
if it was Rihanna it was some female pop
star who's saying I don't care I don't
know the world anything you know you're
beautiful show the world who you are
that was all of them yes it was all of
them so who are scars and all and I
think this is a good way to look at it
because I've struggled with this and
I've tried to be honest with you guys
about a lot of my shortcomings and
issues that I struggle with you know
I've talked about some of my problems my
personal problems sometimes sometimes
I've talked about health problems and
how I've gotten through some health
mistakes that I've made mental health
issues dealing with anger so a scar is a
good example just show the world your
scar and be proud of all second okay
let's go with that what is a scar a scar
is tissue that's healed it was a wound
it's healed so you're not going forward
and telling people you don't need it's
not authentic to be proud of it before
it's a scar it's taking pride in how you
healed that scar oh you know what I was
I was incredibly overweight I was
unhealthy I was on the trails of
diabetes but look that tissue scarred
over I got my health in control I was
depressed I was bipolar I thought I had
issues meant mentally so I went and I
sought help and I surrounded myself with
better people I started making better
decisions and look that's a scar that
healed so let me show look at this scar
you can heal it - there's that's very
different from just saying hey listen
I'm fat and I'm a turnip and I'm proud
that's not a scar that's bleeding all
over the carpet that's an open wound
there's a big difference we don't we
know all those people who just like you
look at me like all right are you ever
planning on getting your life together
right you ever don't judge don't judge
I'm I'm authentic no you're just a man
there's a life suck yes and you're
bleeding like I ran you're just you're
bleeding all over the carpet I don't
want you that's very different from a
scar and so if you're looking at this
and that's one thing we try to do with
this show listen I'm a Christian I'm not
a good I'm not a perfect example I talk
about that all the time I try to be open
about my face if you want to talk about
it
great we can talked about I try not to
proselytize there are enough podcasts
out there that do that and they're not
open about their faults but I'm never
gonna take pride in sin or bad behavior
or a wound that is I think the
delineation that people need to be able
to make using what you've overcome to
help other people overcome it or I don't
say they have to learn the hard way not
everyone has to learn the hard way I
don't want people to learn the hard way
that's why you show them your scars this
I have a small scar here you know what
that was that was chickenpox
I was told not to itch it I hitched it
so do you know what I tell my nephew
knees don't hit your chicken pox
right that's urgent is such a good job I
can't even see it doesn't happen that to
me I hate like crap I ain't nothing but
pop-tarts so I tell people don't do that
you might not you might need an effin if
you have any scars any surgeries oh yes
right well there's nothing really good
do about that no here's here's a here's
a scar this is from punching through
drywall okay warning okay
scarred healed over when you if it I
with with anger issues what hurts is
when you pull back drywall is sharp I
have a scar right here from running into
my own Center playing flag football I
tell people now all the time every day
don't do that there you know how do you
heal it don't be a stupid person don't
be a stupid person get your anger issues
in control and don't punch drywall it
hurts I'm not gonna go hey look look at
me I'm proud that I made a stupid
mistake and punched through drywall
because I didn't control my temper and
now I'm bleeding look at this you need
to accept me I go Hasan you're bleeding
you're bleeding right you're all over my
fresh towels Oh what you're judging yes
and it's okay to judge it's okay to make
judgments and it's okay to have scars
but you shouldn't take pride in being a
walking festering open wound and that's
all I was getting at with Pastor Mark
Driscoll and we had a lot of questions
from people saying you know listen man I
I find struggle with that balance in
life III find struggle with being open
about my mistakes but also wanting to
set a good example for people are also
not wanting to fall back into those
mistakes there is nothing wrong with the
scar I think absolutely you should show
the world your scars but that also by
the way it's redundant this same pops
right I remember who it is said look I
am perfect the way I am scars and all no
that's redundant you have scars which
means you're not perfect you're not
helping anyone by saying look at my
scars I'm perfect to be honest about the
fact that they are imperfections or you
are lying to yourself and you are lying
to the people you could potentially help
stop with this stupid analogy of the
scars scars heal heal your wounds then
you have something to be proud about
otherwise guess what the rest of the
world even if they say they're not these
message aboard your support groups
they're gonna be judging you and they
have every right to judge you because
you're a walking open room wound who
hasn't gotten your crap together
scars great wounds not so much next week
by the way um I think it's gonna big
show it could also be the entire week
could be one big pustule of an open
wound you never know that's the roll of
the dice
[Music]